hey guys this is Inka and this time I
will only be eating blue foods for 24
hours this is probably the most
requested one color food challenge so I
have been doing a lot of research but
unfortunately there really are just not
that many naturally blue foods in the
world and a lot of the ones that I was
hoping to find I couldn't find them here
in New York
apparently the blue Lobster and I don't
know if this is true but the odds of
catching one is like one in 200 million
but with that being said I will try to
find most if not all of the remaining
blue foods and this time I am starting
with the internet I feel like a lot of
the things that I want to find I might
not be able to find in store but I know
that they have them online just to be
safe you guys first off we have this
butterfly pea flower tea drink places
use it to make like blue themed drinks I
also found this blue magic powder so the
blue magic powder is a dietary
supplement essentially its spirulina
extract this type of blue-green algae
that has a lot of health benefits I also
got this blue cornmeal I thought this
would be really fun for us to work with
next thing as per usual I am going to
head to I think at least two verse three
stores just to explore our options and
see what we can find that's blue
[Music]
so we're not gonna go for it
- kombucha that is a beautiful blue
because blue spirulina to make blue
which is advised
[Music]
never happy before
[Music]
good morning everyone it is a gloomy day
today in New York it is raining outside
which I guess is on brand since today is
a blue food today I am excited but also
nervous about today because there isn't
too much to work with but I'm gonna try
to make the most out of it for breakfast
I found this juice shop this juice place
that actually sells blue magic smoothie
bowls it basically looks like an acai
bowl but blue so I think I'm gonna head
over there and buy us some breakfast
I will check back in with you guys when
I'm on the way I am walking to the juice
shop now hopefully I find what I'm
looking for they were to make this day
start off a lot easier
[Music]
my smoothie Bowl I also got this drink
they both use blue spirulina as coloring
so I'm excited to try it I am going to
head back to the office now though so I
can sit down and eat this properly we
made it to the office there's a lot of
blue I think because the blueberries
were kind of smushed so there are a lot
more purple here usually for their
protein bows you can order like three
toppings I basically said I wanted three
servings and blueberries because
everything else they weren't blue oh my
goodness look at this bloop oh oh wow
the blueberries are definitely still
frozen so I'm just gonna mix it together
smells really good there's a lot of
things that went into this but the blue
spirulina really did just make it into
this like super blue looking Bowl I'm
just gonna go right for it big bite
brain freeze I think everything else in
this bowl right now kind of covers
however the spirulina tastes but I like
it and obviously the Rose and
blueberries are really good I will say
though that the fact that it is blue
does kind of come off as intimidating
I'm crazy to think that this is all
natural we've come to associate like
blue with just anything that's unnatural
I have to run to a meeting now and I'm
curious to know what everybody else is
going to think what do you have can I
show you my breakfast it smells good
though it's not oh it does smell good
it's a colored a blue it's a blue
colored a the meeting is now over people
said it smelled nice I actually really
like this shade of blue even though yeah
it does look more like paint than actual
food this is super filling which is
really nice actually I really thought
that today I'd be starving this is
definitely sustenance we're off to a
great start gonna clean up a little bit
and then go work and I'll see you guys
for lunch
we are back here in the tasty studio
it's a little weird but I feel like I'm
still really full from breakfast there
was a lot of ingredients packed into
that bowl a lot of nutrients which is
probably a good thing based on what you
guys saw when I went grocery shopping
there weren't actually that many things
most of it was like drinks or powder but
I think I have enough to work with so
I'm gonna show you guys what I have for
lunch we have red cabbage I found this
hack that can turn this red cabbage into
blue so we're going to test that out
today purple or blue potato it goes by
both names blue corn tacos from that
taco kit I found blue potato chips made
from naturally blue potato you really
only have four items but I think I can
make some sort of taco with potato and
cabbage inside I'm gonna start off by
cutting up the potatoes into bite-size
pieces to put into the taco shell I know
right now it's super purple but once we
cook it this color will change into a
purplish blue so be patient with me
while we continue to do this got my
potatoes toss this in I think I'll check
on this after I finish cooking the
cabbage the hack I found was that if you
add baking soda to red cabbage it
becomes blue I'm planning on adding a
bit of baking soda when I'm sauteing
the red cabbage and hopefully that will
turn it into blue cabbage grabbing a
blue spatula toss this in I'm just gonna
cook it a little bit before adding
anything else I wanted to become a
little more soft you see how the colors
change slightly this is what we were
originally working with and this is the
color is to become potatoes are pretty
much ready so I will take them out there
it is our blue potatoes so now that the
cabbage is a little softer I am going to
add some baking soda
you guys see that instant color change
it's definitely a like aqua blue color
I'm going to turn the stove off I think
at this point it really is the plating
this is what we have there's three
different colors of blue going on
there's that really beautiful blue
coming from the potatoes the greenish
blue with the red cabbage plus baking
soda the taco shell is more of a greyish
blue the blue potato chips kind of
turned out more a vibrant purple which I
wasn't expecting I guess that just means
they retained more of it's like raw
purple color honestly not bad at all if
you see the potatoes is very very soft
the cabbage is a little more interesting
I feel like the baking soda definitely
changes the flavor a little bit slimy
textures not sure if I would normally do
that but color wise you can see that
they all kind of blend together blue is
my favorite color though so I am all for
it
remember how I also bought an extra
drink that features blue magic and
electrolytes which it says right here
and I wanted to show you guys what blue
magic is because I was so curious to
know what it was really in an extract
for healthy joints I'm gonna pour some
of this out whoa instantly you can see
how blue it is this is crazy this is
completely natural believe it or not
it's such a pretty vibrant blue super
pigmented it does smell a little funky I
have to say fishy but I guess since it
does come from algae that wouldn't make
a lot of sense yeah I do not get any of
that blue magic flavor
there's also lime juice lemon juice
maple syrup in here it makes sense that
it's covered by the other things all
natural Gatorade
honestly I think they pretty much just
taste like regular potato chips just
like how the blue potatoes I had it's
just that it is this blue - I almost add
blue - full I've said blue too many
times today it's really just visually
different it's nice sometimes to you
know add a little bit of color to your
plates alright so I'm just gonna be here
finishing up my lunch
not sure if I'm actually gonna be
snacking anything later I'm feeling
pretty full surprisingly I remember how
I told you guys that I
have a snack today so apparently it was
gotta let myself in first
apparently Alvin said he got me a small
dessert so I am taking a break from work
to go see what it is the upper shelf of
the fridge in a blue bag whoo excited is
the box everything is blue super on Brad
there's a note I don't know how to make
macarons so I got you a blue one from
the store they said that the color is
natural but he forgot the flavor and
that he ate the rest of the macarons he
bought classic this is so pretty I love
this I wonder if it's also the blue
magic powder that everybody's been using
almost like a foodie sweetness it was
exactly the type of thing I needed Wow
thanks Alvin appreciate it
yay all right time for me to go back to
work now
I'm meeting with Alvin and he brought
back some snacks and this this is blue
this was made with what butterfly pea
flower amazing taking up the coconut
sure there yeah that's good just tastes
like sticky rice I think it's because I
didn't eat the sugar well this isn't
ready more desserts than I thought I
would have great stuff I am back home so
there's two things I really want to do
one is dinner of course and the other is
dessert I know I had a little dessert
snack earlier but I really wanted to try
and make a blue dessert myself but first
things first let's start off with dinner
we pretty much only have two things when
is the blue car meal which I plan on
using to make some cornbread and then we
have some blue corn tortilla chips I do
have some left over of blue red cabbage
from earlier so I'm going to eat that
with this meal too just to get rid of
veggies in I think playing with this
would be quite fun I would say it's like
a very faint blue oh I already got
started on making the cornbread batter
this is what it looks like now this is
pretty much the color of the cornmeal we
bought so I'm just gonna put this now
into the baking pan and then pop it in
the oven
while I'm waiting for the cornbread to
bake I am going to get started on
dessert so the dessert I wanted to do
today is pretty much just the butterfly
pea flower tea but in jelly form I
really hope this works really are just
flower petals it's like an oddly herbal
smell oh did you guys see that I love
how it instantly turned blue this is so
cool oh yeah oh so I'm just gonna let
this steep for a while it's been about
15 minutes and I wanted to show you guys
what the butterfly DT looks like look at
that it's so blue I love it I can't
believe this is natural coloring right
now I'm gonna combine this with some
more water and then we're gonna add in
the agar agar and then we can pour it
out into the molds so now that the jelly
is in the fridge the cornbread is pretty
much done I just took it out of the oven
and I am super excited if you guys take
a look at this you can see the blue
peeking through it just smells amazing
in here so I am super glad I'm like
salivating that's why I can't even talk
I am really really looking forward to
this I'm just going to let this cool and
then next time you see me I will have
this plate it and will be ready to eat
excited the meal is completed here is
the final reveal this is my meals right
here there's like different shades of
blue going on purplish blue the
cornbread it's like a little darker than
the normal cornbread you can see the
blue cornmeal inside it's not like that
super vibrant blue you would expect a
blue cabbage from earlier I feel like
after it sits for a while it becomes
even more blue it's almost like a
turquoise kind of blue over here I have
some blue ice that I made earlier they
are super pretty I'm super proud of
these I made this blue ice with some
black goji berries this is what the
black goji berries look like it also
gives that like vibrant blue color I
have this kombucha super super blue
drink
it has kombucha in it coconut water
ginger juice
and blue magic which I feel like has
been featured very heavily this episode
yeah
now that's pretty epic Percy Jackson
would be so proud
this is incredible wait you guys have to
look at this it's like solid shapes of
blue in a sea of blue tastes really good
again
I don't taste the Blue Magic portion
because there was combined with ginger
juice it's the ginger that stands out
the most even though it's completely
blue it tastes just like a lemon and
ginger kombucha which is amazing I want
to start with the cornbread it really
did smell so amazing all I did really
was just following a basic cornbread
recipe but substituting regular cornmeal
with blue cornmeal the blue is very very
subtle I'm gonna go right for it this is
really good I don't know if there is too
much of a difference between corn bread
made with a regular cornmeal and blue
cornmeal
but I do feel like the flavor and this
one is a little nuttier I really like
this cornbread I only cut three slices
here but I'm pretty sure I'll be eating
all of it because I'm hungry
you want me to show you guys this
cabbage again it sounds like seaweed at
this point and I have the blue corn
tortilla chips like they're pretty
popular it almost tastes a little bit
sweeter and it feels grainy er which I
kind of like I like it when chips have
like different textures it's not as like
smooth and refined I'm a big fan of blue
corn apparently I didn't know that until
now if you haven't had a chance to try
blue corn tortilla chips maybe try and
grab a bag next time when you're buying
chips and salsa I feel like you guys
would like this too
I'm very pleased with this dinner I am
going to finish this off give it a few
hours before we dig into dessert I
finally finished cleaning up I am ready
for dessert so I took the jelly that I
made
you're out and they came out pretty cool
hold on let me show you guys tada
I added in some blueberries for
decoration also I love the shape of
these molds it's the same one that I
used in my other video where I made
edible jewelry and so these came out
super pretty I try one now
whoa how cool is that color they're very
comforting shade of blue and this again
was all just the doing of the butterfly
Petey there is no artificial food
coloring in here at all because it's
agar agar it's like a clean cut there's
a little bit of sugar before the most
part is still tastes like the butterfly
Petey it's like sweetened herbal tea and
a blueberry to end it off so that is the
end of my blue color food challenge I
hope you guys enjoyed it as always I had
a lot of fun putting these creative
dishes together for you also this time I
will be linking some of the things that
I used in the description box below if
you guys ever want to try this challenge
yourself definitely if you make any one
color food dishes send them to me I
would love to see them it's always so
fun seeing what you guys can do now that
I've finally done blue foods let me know
what other color you want me to do other
than that I will see you guys in the
next video bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you